what does it mean to understand human
beings as biological creatures as
material as manipulable aside from the
obvious benefits of being able to cure
diseases and an extend life which have
their own implications for societies if
everybody starts to live a long time
what does that mean that's big we've
already experienced a doubling of the
life expectancy worldwide over it you
know a hundred years or so a little
really quite remarkable how that changes
the way societies organize themselves
not in the sense that people say okay
now we're going to get married later and
have fewer children but it happens
partly because of life extension oh you
know there's that sort of the obvious
social consequences but then there's
these sort of deeper philosophical
issues what do you know if we are really
material what does that mean how do we
think about that what do we think about
consciousness if it's an emergent
property of you know chemical reactions
as opposed to a little ghost in your
head does that make you feel worse about
yourself in the same way that maybe a G
if you have to give up the you know
there was a universe centered on earth
and man does that make you feel worse
about yourself you know amazingly enough
we got used to that and we we don't feel
worse about ourselves than we did with
the earth as the center of the universe
so I think we'll get over this other two
but but it raises a lot of issues you
know what do you do about when you find
the biological roots of certain kinds of
criminal behavior or socially
destructive behavior how do you deal
with that it's deep difficult question
you know especially if the person hasn't
actually done anything bad how do you
think about that or if they have done
something bad and you can say we
identified the gene that led to this
personality disorder you know how does
that get them off if they killed six
people or something in a way so that I
think is one big area
Oh